this is the niche um bills up for that
anything man you know as a guide to the
Zen thing I'll say into myself and stop
there and it stops just at the point
where I'm like yes that they know just
with a Tory
um so okay so uh Billy once again voiced
by a Lou Ferrigno is um concerned
because Finn had this dream this dream
that McDowell that you have the cosmic
owl in it uh was actually I got a lot of
imagery in this one was legitimate
nightmarish and not just like oh look
scary imagery or so it's like just the
sir feeling and pacing and where their
place and everything I mean it seemed
genuinely like kind like a fever dream
ah but which I which I liked um there's
like one part we see one frame of
something I think catchment was AC
delicious face for like two seconds or
something yeah you know the one frame of
diamond yeah yeah um and so Finn goes
and tells Billy Billy says it's
important that we get all the jewels
that like I guess every crown in the
world has pretty much um and we put it
in the book the I always get the name it
was a reading the ink I Rhydian uh and
that's going to open up a portal that
can ya portal I could connect to any
different kind of universe um and Billy
says he's gonna put the Lynch in there
clue number one man cool number watch it
I'm gonna throw the Lich in there it's
just like no no no first I thought they
were in cahoots I thought that's what
was going on but turns out the Lich
actually is Billy uh or Billy is the
hitch something like that oh dear little
bit Conan a little bit cold Billy
um and so okay gets the last jewel which
is Bubblegum's jewel um
she's doing some fucked up experiments
yeah seriously I
don't go running around cuttin people's
lives off sorry I didn't seem to mind
they just said smile they were like
whatever
maybe I'm just used to it by now then
that was my thing that I liked hard and
that it's fine enough just seeing her
with you know the pad and just watching
them this weird scenario array that's
really quiet ventures
I just put stuff right so that was
really funny um and uh I'm offended for
candy people so Finn comes in gets the
jewel from her after she accidentally
cuts him with the scissors and he is
just feeling very bitter towards her
again it seems like and turns out Billy
is the Lich and Finn thinks if he
destroys the book that'll do and take
that destroy the book it doesn't it
creates the giant a parallel universe
opener upper and uh Finn and Jake could
drag down along with the Lich and it
ends with sort of a different drawing of
Finn in this more earthly looking realm
except he has a robotic arm Jake doesn't
seem to be talking and he lives on a
farm
what's this sir yeah the son apologies
oh yeah weirdo and and he has a mother
at least and she called him inside
wearing pink Oh
Freudian and yes that it just stops
there so I don't know we're watching it
just like it stopped it stopped and it
starts it like yeah that's perfect place
to end it and this isn't season finale
oh that's really yes this oh my god I
was thinking for this one was the season
finale yeah no that's a good good
planning guy Adventure Time II that is a
perfect place to leave off um so uh yeah
like I said the the whole thing kind of
felt just uncomfortable but in a good
way
like I saw watching it like I'm even
sore the interaction with Peebles was
just kind of just kind of uncomfortable
the way they're looking at you
it's just like this underlying kind of
anger and hate throughout most of it and
maybe that's just what I'm trying to get
across with the Lich being around or
that eats impersonating him or something
but it hissed at her yeah no no sir uh
and yeah I just I really so see this one
more than any of the others which is
saying a lot just sort of like this
really uncomfortable dream like even
when Jake is like you know and zoom in
and it keeps zooming in and up over and
over in the music advils he's like ah
stop man it's like I don't know I have
really uncomfortable dreams like that
before where something just keeps
repeating it's like just stop stop um
and yeah I just got this really like
this bad vibe but it but it's
intentional lightly yeah you know uh you
know and the made the Lich look nice and
scary especially what's the half Billie
half Lich face um and uh yeah I'm
watching this and I'm always impressed
that within 11 minutes they can create
this very big you know sort of you know
especially for a season finale in 11
minutes to do that and leave on such a
good cliffhanger um you know it's it's
really good and I also like the fact
that they clearly show Finn has a
robotic arm because otherwise they'd
just be like oh they're in our world
yeah you know I because there's nothing
else there it looks like our world but
the robotic arm still shows what
something's up something's that this
isn't just reality or whatever so yeah
if there's one episode I don't remember
the episode but there was an episode
with mirrors and I said well here face
princess Lee know King worm they think
that's it was that her thing was a
twisted dreamer to the King worm and he
looked in the mirror
and there he saw himself but he had that
robotic arm in the this rocks a clue he
had the remote
Shamir coming to really the fact that's
the right arm possibly cuz it was the
right arm in the mirror it's the right
arm here yeah it's the exact same image
that was in the mirror yeah and don't
you say that mirrors are a gateway to
like you said in a dream you can't see
in a mirror because of some or also in
the comments that said dreams are a
gateway to the future uh which would
that was definitely someone in the
comments we might make perfect sense see
me okay the future
well he done what even before they said
he has like premonition dreams or at
least he always thinks the premonition
trees jcat apparently a premonition
dream because cuz we go yeah that the
cosmic al okay so the cosmic owl is
always in a dream it's like hey take
notice this is important crap okay yeah
that's why you know oh it's a croak
dream I'm supposed to die I'm gonna die
by with it yeah mmm the cosmic owl said
so okay um and yeah so I really that's
like the one element where you can't
just be like oh they're in reality
because it's you know like it'd still be
interesting what's gonna happen but
you're like oh a parallel universe and
we're the other universe whatever but by
having a robotic arm it's just all the
more wait what is that
well what's going on with that um so
yeah I really enjoyed it I like uh I
liked sorry this uncomfortable feeling
throughout the whole thing and I like
the imagery and I thought it came across
really good joy yeah yeah this was
really neat and and I agree with you
completely if there was just something
off about the whole episode not in a bad
way but in um once you started talking
about it it hit me yeah it's almost like
the Lich's presence is causing this
little bit you know it's kind of leaking
into everybody why like fin hissing at
bubblegum is is unreal it's just unreal
it's almost and actually even the idea
of them I mean they asked why should we
steal it shouldn't we just ask you know
and
like no no no we gotta hurry up with
this we gotta save the world they just
seem so ready to go ahead and just steal
from everybody it was this weird energy
I guess well even when you say are you
ready to help me on a journey where you
know we're gonna save the entire cosmos
or something like that I mean Finn
dazeem ago I was thinking like okay and
find spot too you know yeah there's some
like this is like yes yeah and like
nothing else I'm like yeah that was even
like I mean I guess it's so strange it's
kind of funny but it's definitely not
haha funny I was just like that's a lot
and ever yet everything in here I I
think in the on the nail there there's
every time I even think of the Lich
episodes it's strange because I don't
see him as like a traditional like yeah
that guy's gonna haunt my dreams
everything but yeah there's always
something just genuinely uncomfortable
with those episodes you know even
weights just the little snail it's just
they're like yeah I don't know like the
one where the bear brings it into the
book and he's like excellent I mean
that's just a little dump done clincher
but it's like I genuinely don't feel
good it's our descent I know so little
about the character I mean you know I
marry as a cool design but I don't
remember too much else I just remember
sort of this weird feeling you know in
every episode that he's in so I guess
and maybe that is the intention the only
other thing is that this it just makes
me question so many goddamn things it's
not even funny like are we now gonna see
like an episode or so of like the new or
the other world finn and jake dynamic
are we gonna or is that them when they
switched over they became that i mean
it's like so many different
possibilities branching out and I can't
decide and I can't choose and I just
really want to watch the next one
because no because did they become these
or is there gonna be our Jake and then
that jr. yes altogether what about I
mean it's just oh and how are they gonna
get back are they gonna get back okay
I'm time today I'm playing bioshock
infinite right now god and just that's a
very interesting game to play like I I
think we're in like the last third of
the game it's at that's an interesting
game to play for this episode
to suddenly come on you know I was just
like wow like I I'm very much playing a
game very similar to this right now so
ya know it's um definitely a lot of fun
style I guess I really think that
robotic garb is the big like for me
that's the clincher like that's the you
got to come back and see what the hell's
going on because outside I like you say
it could just be another reality or a
real world or something like that but
that is like like that's intriguing that
is okay what is going on with that so
Jason um this is the one that made my
jaw hit the floor
oh wow Bandung er no um for me and I
took it a very different way I guess
when he asked when Billy goes to Jake
you know or to Finn you ready to hit the
world with me
I think his response was like are you
fucking kidding me you're asking me to
do this with my hero of all time it was
just kind of one of those yes whatever
you want yes remember Billy is the one
that Billy Jake aspire to be like
without question and that's kind of how
I took that response yeah it was bizarre
it was strange Oh should we ask well you
know we don't have time oh okay you know
yeah it was a bit weird for me what made
me hit my jaw hit the floor personally
was when that shot hits Billy and you it
was revealed that he was the Lich that
just think about it from Finn's
perspective the Lich killed Billy
skinned him and is wearing his skin is
that yeah yeah yeah is that what we're
today is that what you're supposed to
take out of this house is supposed to be
I don't know it's magic you can do magic
himself to look like Billy I don't even
take it off and when he got shot why
would part of it just peel away
I don't know magic skin yeah I I don't
know I mean it was definitely a
disturbing image like a life for me it
was he was this entire time he's been
wearing this skin but was he also the
snake
whoever remember the dream the snail is
reading from the enchiridion I'm seeing
the shadow humbly mumbling yeah it turns
into the hole that's right okay and then
he takes now okay that does make more
sense now okay so this entire time that
Finn has been on this adventure an
adventure he's been dying to do since we
first found out about Billy
remember when they're riding on Jake
Finn takes off his hat yeah I know he
could look like Jimmy's got such a smile
this is the thing he's been dying to do
for his entire life pretty much and in
that one second where that shot hits and
the smoke clears and you see part Billy
and part the Lich and you see Finn's
face of oh my god I have been on the
adventure of my life with my ultimate
enemy just imagine how scarring that
would be to a kid lion especially the
fact that like you said he just wasn't
questioning anything it's like he was
blindly going along with it uh you know
even against his better judgment even
like when I think bubblegum says that
was an axe or something I mean most any
other time he'd be like you know okay
it's cool but come on I really gotta
help Billy I got a blob out how you like
this is that or if he's like so consumed
by doing something with a zero that he
was turning against his better judgment
and people that he knows are good people
yeah you know uh cutting off their lazy
dog but yeah they didn't seem to mind I
guess so but for my mind for me it was
the whole I mean I kind of knew
something was kind of funky going on but
that revealed that the Lich had been
wearing Billy skin the entire time and
just I'm picturing in my head you know
as a kid I grew up watching Robo tech my
favorite character was Maximilian
Stirling and I would just like what
seriously I was just picturing in my
head
if max showed up and said hey let's go
up in a fair attack we're gonna go do
this and we're going to help and save
everyone I wouldn't question I'd be like
yes and then to find out that in the end
he's actually like the mortal enemy it's
like think about how much that would
just screw with a kid
like it say especially with him hurting
others yes I mean the thing yeah so for
me I didn't get at the weird undertones
but I think it was also done with the
music the music was very well done is
very yeah they want small um the comedic
moments were small yeah I was gonna say
the last like maybe three minutes I was
like plus they're even a laugh I don't
think there was oh you didn't mention
the embryo princess oh my god yeah
that's pretty much bearing a Crim almost
like Bubblegum's I'm like it's bubblegum
pregnant um with uh lumpy Space Princess
how all of them come up yeah no no no
any loot yeah that one I was kind of
wondering what is that gonna come into
play later is that just a joke you know
just like don't you have no carpet
everything and then I really like the
art style for one that the in Caribbean
got the last gem close yeah all the way
the lower came around open that that was
fun like there's sobered fluid out great
I mean huge fan of horror movies and
this is just one of those that kind of
as an adult seen us from a kid's
perspective and a kid watching it I can
see this messing with someone messing
with the kid messing with their mind and
everything and the first time I saw this
I actually watched it at night with all
the lights out like I just had going and
I was like and like you know maybe
that's what helped feed it was the
environment I was in but it was one of
those where I'm like that's gonna fuck
with some kids like I can see that oh I
can totally see that
how many kids shows have something like
that yes they'll have a villain die very
rarely but you know they'll have like a
villain hero die sorry but to where that
person's skin that's the thing that I
was like how can they do this there's no
blood yes
but that's exactly what's going on here
well and it didn't even dawn on me
honestly watching it because all the
dreams have always been premonitions it
didn't even Donna me that's what was
currently going on yeah when you brought
that up and so I did you see he was
reading the book it's like Oh like and
then I still have to go back like
let's have it yeah that's right he grows
big and then he takes the ledge and say
it's like yeah that's right I really hit
and the bear and it's like I suddenly
had to really think well that's like
what actually happened for the balls by
me fit obviously wasn't look at the
theatre oh yeah that we know maybe some
house of twists in the next oh yeah no
it's uh you know for a show I again I
like shows like this that can really
bring something really bright very
colorful upbeat energetic but because of
that it's also earned its right to be
ungodly dark yeah when it wants to be
but within within reason you know it's
not like you know oh hey we have to have
a dark one at some point or half of our
live years some there have have to be
dark it's not like there's a quota
edia hey if this just seems to match
what the characters are going through
and it seems to be just where the story
takes it it's allowed to be taken there
yeah it's earned its right to be that
dark and I guess I don't know it's like
um you know me I'd find my dark stop and
movies and shows and stuff but there is
sort of this sense uh I guess now and
like maybe a few years ago and stuff but
we're like you know hey because it was
dark it was good and it was risky and it
was smart and it's like I just don't buy
that sometimes if it's just dark but
it's still dumb and it's not built up
very well and it doesn't flow it's it's
still dumb doesn't build up very well
doesn't flow okay it's dark but so what
just showing torture doesn't make it
interesting yeah showing torture of the
character you care about and done in a
proper way that's gonna make it yeah
exactly so um so yeah like I said I
think these episodes there's definitely
stuff cuz people are like well how keep
you so pro like Return to Oz and so anti
you know like some other kids movie
that's way too dark or me in spirit or
something like that and so Lisa if if
the characters and the story are strong
enough and that's the direction it very
naturally annoyingly takes it there it
works if it's just dark just mean and it
hasn't earned it then there's it's just
exactly that it hasn't earned it I think
a change your time to think very much is
are
ya know I think I think you just said it
right there's dark and then there's mean
mmm there is dark like return to us dark
where it's like you're watching like now
that's a messed up imagery but it's not
there to just it's not you don't you
seller in the background getting their
leg cut cut ah for the sake of just
having it there it's messed up imagery
it's dark it's kind of creepy here and
there but it fits the mood when you see
other kids movies where it's just like
oh we're gonna have this in there in the
background just to show how messed up we
are yeah and I don't know we can be done
that's always what feel like they want
to show up that they can be dark and
they can do dark stuff and it's like
that's everybody time to do it yeah it's
like everybody has in themselves the
ability to be really dark really messed
up really mean and stuff like that you
know it's I think people always think
well if I can show that I can be that
people think like I deeper or that I'm
being risque and or shocking like hey
he's doing what we think they should so
they're the artists or the poet and it's
there's still work that has to go into
it like I said it has to very carefully
be done and I think these are very
carefully done and they are well paced
and they are very well put together and
like I said I think they they built up
to it
um and any balance is out very ver yeah
and you you again hit the nail on the
head I keep forgetting these shows are
11 minutes long yeah
I get so drawn in when I watch that I
don't realize it it's only been 11
minutes if this completes yeah that's
the thing I've seen a lot of 11 minute
shows and these are so well written and
so well done that it feels like a
complete like like I've just watched an
hour episode or there's an hour's worth
of content because I've seen shows under
an hour long and I'm like man this is
just dumb there's so much useless things
here there's stuff here I don't need to
you know you're dragging this out these
feel like you've watched like a full
hour episode because it has that much
info that has that much like going on
but you get done you're like only
cracked asleep at 11 minutes that's
awesome when we watch for the emperor
fools when we did the My Little Pony
episode oh yeah
I remember saying like you know wow this
is really long and I realized no it's
not I'm just so used to watching 11
minutes worth of material here like oh
yeah 24 minutes that's what most shouts
are but I think you're right this show
got it right Darryl they're at 11
minutes and they get everything in there
now at 11 minutes
yeah and there's very little time
there's there's no space to waste time
and which makes it even funnier when
they do yeah but the few times they are
like you know they'll just be singing a
song and I'll sort of say that's right
the opening when Jake it's like I have a
dream that I was a teacher of the Khitan
Al's Bank kindergarten and my feet were
big and I was the teacher let's go
yeah edits it's just great as you know
how precious time is in these episodes
from so for a line like that to get
attention or let me dive employer LSPs
which in the hangar oh yeah you're gonna
do whatever to take it out we use gonna
do and they're like oh gross so ya know
it's uh is good I I can't wait to see
what happens next
so let's go find out let's do it they're
not moving very fast
I'm not moving anymore was it my couch
I'm gonna go put it on as well I got
very a possible god damn it
aren't you fast I can slow down slower
that that's better take a nap when I
wake up it better be on
Jesus fell over it take his wallet